the first Convoy of humanitarian Aid has
arrived in nagorna kanabakh after the
recent fighting people say they have
little food fuel or electric power
Azerbaijan has tightened its grip on the
region dominated by ethnic Armenians
after ceasefire earlier this week
videos have emerged of Russian
peacekeepers delivering Aid after
Azerbaijan claimed full control of The
Enclave it's internationally recognized
as part of Azerbaijan the Red Cross has
also sent a convoy of aid
meanwhile hundreds of ethnic Armenians
are stranded at nagorna karabakh's main
airport they gathered at what is now a
Russian peacekeeping base residents say
they're in search of protection
my grandchildren are with me they are
frightened and shaking with fear they
cannot sleep at night Russian
peacekeepers are here and we think it
will be safe so we stay at the airport
although we sleep 12 people in a car
across the border a U.S Congressional
Delegation is in Armenia to meet prime
minister Nicole pashinyan the visit
comes at a time of mass protests against
pushinyan for his handling off the
conflict
the foreign Ministers of Azerbaijan and
Armenia have raised the conflict in
nagorna karabakh the U.N General
Assembly the azerbaijani envoy said
ethnic Armenians living in The Enclave
will be integrated as equal citizens The
Armenian Envoy pushed for a un mission
to monitor humanitarian conditions
all efforts have now been mobilized to
address the immediate needs of the local
civilians
on this point I wish to reiterate that
Azerbaijan is determined to reintegrate
ethnic Armenian residents of the garbach
region of Azerbaijan as equal citizens
the Constitution the national
legislation of Azerbaijan and the
international commitments who have
undertaken provide the solid ground to
this end
the International Community should
undertake all the efforts for an
immediate deployment of an interagency
Mission by the United Nations to nagorna
Karbach with the aim to Monitor and
access the human rights humanitarian and
security situation on the ground
let's go to a correspondent Osama bin
Javed he joins us now live from the
capital of Azerbaijan in Baku so Osama
good to see you firstly bring us up to
date with the latest developments
well much needed Aid has now reached the
karabakh region we've been hearing from
officials here in Baku who say that the
corridors have been opened uh not just
for the icrc from The Armenian side but
there are more supplies that are going
in from the azerbaijani side as well to
reach these people and as the
azerbaijani government says that it is
responsible for the people who there as
it is azerbaijani territory to tell us
more about it we have an advisor to
president Alief Mr hikmatia with us
thank you very much for joining us tell
us about the situation of the people in
nagorno-karabakh and how is the aid
reaching people
representative also had a meeting with
the representative of Armenia residents
of karabakh region of Azerbaijan and
within that meeting as an abroad agenda
has been discussed and also azerbaijan's
proposals with regards to the social
economic and political reintegration in
the midterm humanitarian issues and on
that meeting we have identified what
other local requirements and needs and
immediately Azerbaijan government has
reacted upon the decree of Azerbaijan
president and under the Deputy Prime
Minister special working group administ
to establish but it involves all
appropriate government institutions we
are receiving inquiries but we
immediately responding to that inquiries
first humanitarian delivery has been
rendered to Karbach Armenians
destination and distributed for the
local residents and in the meantime
there wasn't a special need for oil and
gasoline especially for electricity
generator machines and it also also been
provided yesterday in the meantime we're
working with an icrc and Russian
peacekeepers on the ground and through
their channels also to emulate
humanitarian situation and also to
respond to the needs and requirements on
the ground and Azerbaijan as a Goodwill
gesture ensure that further
operationality of latent fine candy road
for the icrc deliveries to Hein candy
and in the meantime we are also
providing and asking about if anything
any kind of need for the icrc was a
logistic support of azerbaijanic
government and we will ameliorate and in
the meantime icrc asked us for a passage
of additional personal and we also
positively reacted with that in the
meantime we are also assessing the
situation on the ground and trying to
deliver our targeted humanitarian
deliveries to the local population on
the ground but along with that
Azerbaijan is also preparing its own
plan with regards in a short term and
Midterm a political economic and social
reintegration that is going to be my
next question that it is important that
there is stability this flare-up of
violence doesn't happen because the
pictures that we've been seeing from
stepanakert which is known as Han candy
and Azerbaijan is people hunkering in
bunkers a damage to a lot of property
how we're going are you going to avoid
that in the future uh well the situation
is kind of a stable connection except in
some very sporadic actions at a very low
level on the ground uh important thing
is that on the 20th September uh counter
offense has already halted because
counter-terrorism actions on the ground
has been halted and because on the
condition that the local Armed Forces on
the ground and they will disarm and the
disarmament has also restarted and the
mobilization has already started because
yesterday I was in a so-called regime
has already made in a statement by
dissolving their armored forces or
so-called the minister of defense and we
also started the process of collecting
arms and ammunitions but of course is
issue that we have been surprised even
to see such a huge amount of the
ammunitions and weapons accumulated in
the area is probably the most
militarized area on the ground for the
peaceful reintegration process that's
called the DDR the demobilization
disarmament are crucial components of
the peaceful integration processor
this element process is also going on
the ground but with regard to a local
population on the ground and local
residents Azerbaijan is ready to provide
all humanitarian assistance and
azerbaijan's agenda about a peaceful
reintegration as also uh the actions on
the ground once again demonstrated that
how Azerbaijan was uh carefully
approaching with a residents and
civilian residents on the ground and
avoiding why all means any kind of
collateral damage but in the meantime
what we've seen on the ground that
azerbaijan's civilian military and
police are personal on the ground are
helping the civilians and bringing them
to hospitals in case of Terminator and
providing a food and shelter in
immediate aftermath of every complex
situation there are monitoring issues
are emerging but important thing but
first Azerbaijan government has a
stronger willingness and we provide a
rise in security of karabakh residents
and in the meantime we have all
necessary means in terms of humanitarian
support and in terms of the social
economic reintegration there's a
significant announcement that you just
told me about from your president that
there is going to be an amnesty for the
civilians living in stepanakat Khan
Kandi and then but there are some
conditions attached to it can you please
tell us more about it there is no
question as well because
civilians its own uh citizens and we do
perceive the people who've been fighting
against yes with regard to them as part
of the 20th September of halting uh the
counter-terrorist actions Azerbaijan
made it very clear but who puts an
account down uh from the first second
karabakh war 44 Days War and the recent
engagement simple as they're free and
here we should differentiate two groups
of people one group is a serviceman of
the Armed Force of the Republic of
Armenia if they also put a gun down and
they can return back to Republic of
Armenia as part of this this Armament is
also a demobilization process as such
and also local residents who were
holding their arms and if they put also
their guns down and they can return to
their barracks and from there to
demobilize Simply they are free and here
should be
better understanding for than everybody
what is their differentiation
differentiation we are talking about
there are some selective couple of other
people who in the first carvajo
committed crimes of all crimes against
azerbaijani civilians in a broader scale
we are talking about them and mainly
they were at the leadership of the
so-called illegal regime again this
other particular individuals and
selective individuals that we are
talking about that but with the majority
male generation male population we don't
have a problem in a broader sense with
the civilians and we shouldn't have a
problem on the contrary we are inviting
them and we are trying to reach out to
the different channels I would also
really comment the very first fact that
directly direct engagement or Central
azero Government invited representatives
of Armenian residents of caraba to have
a better communication on the report
agenda of the issues including the
political integration model social
economic issues as they asked on certain
issues and central government of
Azerbaijan immediately reacted and will
continue to do so and there are more
intensive meetings are coming forward as
well to meet all of this immediate
requirements thank you very much Mr
where president advisor to the president
here talking to Australian Baku and
significant is the azerbaijani
government saying that it is going to
give amnesty to the people even who had
taken up arms as long as they are not
involved in war crimes as long as
they're not servicemen and uh military
personnel of the Armenian government so
Aid has arrived the situation seems to
be improving and there seems to be no
ultimatum from the azerbaijani sides on
when these forces should lay down their
arms but as the world watches closely it
is a region which has been prone to
violence and any little flare-up can
read to further tensions okay really
good to talk to you Osama bin Javed
there for us in Baku let's go to Sheila
pailand she joins us from armenia's
Capital Yerevan she's an international
human rights lawyer you were listening
into that interview that Osama bin Javed
was doing with that azerbaijani
presidential spokesman and he was very
keen to make that point that ethnic
Armenians will be treated and integrated
as equal citizens
but how did they really feel about it do
they believe that will be the case
um absolutely not nobody believes
that'll be the case uh to the extent
that the azerbaijani government
considers uh the Armenians of Karbach to
be its own citizens they are the most
despised then minority of the country
there's a long-standing uh State policy
of hatred against Armenians that go that
goes back decades that just doesn't stop
overnight
um so and also Azerbaijan has made these
statements before and has acted
completely in contradiction with
statements of that sort there's no
reasonable basis to trust that there
will be any safety or security or rights
protected for the Armenians of karabakh
and they want to leave they they don't
want to live under azerbaijani rule
um so they're asking for the corridor to
be open and for there to be there needs
to be an international uh presence to
assist an evacuation to get the
Armenians out because they are actually
very very much in danger right now and
and what about this idea that we we
heard about amnesties for those
civilians who've actually did take up
arms the azerbaijanis again saying you
know they're going to be fine
do you think does that ring true to you
absolutely not they're not going to be
fine uh any able-bodied man uh Beyond a
certain age is considered a terrorist
it's considered a criminal uh and uh
again like I said Azerbaijan doesn't
keep its promises so we have a situation
where they're not going to be
um they'll that first they'll probably
be arrested detained and then uh
considered for amnesty or not if that's
even true uh most likely that's not
going to be true and they will be put
through Mass trials so it's it's not
it's not you know okay we can hope that
it's true but
there's no action so far from the
azerbaijani government in the last uh in
how many years that suggests that
anything they say is is accurate they
don't uh they want to make a show of
this they want to make a show of we've
won we we got rid of the terrorists
these are not terrorists the disarmament
is not an anti-terrorist operation uh
this this was a defense Army a group of
Armenians who have been living
in fear for three decades uh and and
people are allowed to defend themselves
from violence and aggression this
disarmament process has been too fast
too rapid they have been disarmed and
now they're extremely vulnerable
um
apologies I I wanted to find out what
you're hearing about uh the ordinary
citizens of nagorno-karabakh we
understand many with that food fuel uh
but again we heard from the uh
azerbaijani Minister spokesperson there
saying that Aid is coming in what is the
situation on the ground as far as you
know it
as far as we know and it's hard to know
because there are no International
journalists on the ground uh Azerbaijan
is cutting uh is trying to keep
everything as opaque and not transparent
as possible journalists weren't allowed
to be at the peace talks either the the
recent ones so we do see we did see
yesterday two icrc uh convo trucks uh
reach the illegal checkpoint at the
lodging Corridor at about 4 pm and they
only got through at midnight last night
now this is after nine months of
starving this population two trucks is
not it's too little too late uh the last
one was one one truck from the Octon
Corridor uh two days prior so the the
trickle is is it's just it's almost
meant to keep them barely alive it's not
uh this isn't this isn't real and they
need more than just a little bit of
bread you know they haven't had any
nutrition for for months and months
they're weak there's scared they're
terrified
they don't have a means of communicating
consistently or reliably and they're
burying uh their loved ones in that in
the several hundreds and basically Mass
lined up Graves at the moment you can
imagine how how
broken they are
we heard from The Armenian Envoy at the
U.N pushing for a U.N mission to monitor
the humanitarian conditions and monitor
the situation on the ground how How
likely is it that something like that
will happen
um I hope it's going to happen I I don't
know how likely it is uh it's it's
if it's going to depend on a U.N
security Council consensus and without a
veto of the P5 members it's it it's
almost quite unlikely if it's not that
then then I think we do have a good
chance and it's extremely necessary so
the language around uh there being an
internationally assisted presence
monitoring be it an evacuation is
growing and it's good and it's extremely
necessary right now so I think given how
how dire the situation is uh the the
human rights lawyer me is going to say
we're there this is coming so I I I'm
going to be optimistic that that will
get this Convoy thank you so much for
your time Sheila palan joining us there
from Yerevan international human rights
lawyer thank you